there are a bunch of us in this business
this show business we're in where if I'm
walking down the street and people see
me and they they want you know upbeat
Conan and I am pretty upbeat most the
time but they if I don't if I'm not
feeling it they still want me to be that
cone and when I take a selfie with them
I feel like you're lucky because you're
your character that everyone knows you
for is this guy right here you always
look like you're just about to nod off
and you get to be that guy in a selfie
right I do
people are so disappointed when I open
my mouth and I start to talk and I go
that's not my yeah right but when I if I
met you on the street I don't want to
know what you read lately I don't know
if everybody knows where you went to
school which I'm jealous of but you also
read a lot what did that come from
well but corporate looking at my my
online history we went somewhere one
time and that restaurant in Hollywood
and you we're talking about what you
just read oh I like to read I like to
read but you know that's not interesting
to people well yeah no III do I do like
to read I'm a man of letters if you will
so what are you reading
well III this is I didn't even think the
show would turn into a discussion of
what I was reading I'm reading right now
I just finished an amazing book about
how the Third Reich I can't believe
we're talking about this Third Reich
they methamphetamines were pretty much
invented by companies by several
companies before the Third Reich and
it's what fueled a lot of the soldiers
during the Third Reich and a lot of the
upper echelons of the Third Reich and
probably contributed to some insane
behavior well I find that interesting
and thank you there you go it's called
blitz
the book is called quit check it out all
right we're going to cut that part out
now are you will you really cry well we
don't know whenever whenever we
mentioned Nazi speed fruits we leave it
in yeah that's a rule
you